Vanessa Bryant breaks her silence after
the tragic deaths of her husband Kobe
Bryant and 13 year old daughter Gianna
writing on Instagram my girls and I want
to thank the millions of people who've
shown support and love during this
horrific time thank you for all the
prayers we definitely need them we are
completely devastated by the sudden loss
of my adoring husband Kobe the amazing
father of our children and my beautiful
sweet Gianna a loving thoughtful and
wonderful daughter and amazing sister to
Natalia Bianca and Capri we are all so
devastated for the families who lost
their loved ones on Sunday and we share
in their grief
intimately there aren't enough words to
describe our pain right now I take
comfort in knowing that Kobe and Gigi
both knew that they were so deeply loved
we were so incredibly blessed to have
them in our lives I wish they were here
with us forever
they were our beautiful blessings taken
from us too soon I'm not sure what our
lives hold beyond today and it's
impossible to imagine life without them
but we wake up each day trying to keep
pushing because Kobe and our baby girl
Gigi are shining on us to light the way
our love for them is endless and that's
to say immeasurable I just wish I could
hug them kiss them and bless them have
them here with us forever
thank you for sharing your joy your
grief and your support with us we ask
that you grant us the respect and
privacy we will need to navigate this
new reality to honor our team Mamba
family the Mamba Sports Foundation has
set up the Mamba on three fund to help
support the other families affected by
this tragedy to donate please go to
Mamba on 3 org to further Kobe and
Gianna's legacy in youth sports please
visit Mamba sports foundation org thank
you so much for lifting us up in your
prayers and for loving Kobe GG Natalia
Bianca Capri and
me